good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is like Alice's doc McStuffins
leggo it comes to you in only one part
part 1 the news I'm of course referring
Hank to the El Chapo news so a couple
weeks ago I got a text from my
mother-in-law that said you need to read
the El Chapo story in The Washington
Post
el chapo for those unfamiliar with his
work is he currently imprisoned alleged
leader of the Sinaloa drug cartel and
according to The Washington Post article
in question the world's most notorious
drug lord he's known for his
ruthlessness and daring prison escapes
and from everything I can gather he's
like not the kind of person you want as
an enemy so I'm gonna tread pretty
lightly here Hank because I am nothing
if not a coward right so anyway I start
reading the article which details some
concerns that El Chapo's lawyer has
about the conditions of El Chapo's
imprisonment it's reported for instance
that Oh chapo is only allowed to watch
one hour of television per day and also
that during his 65 days in Juarez prison
he has only been allowed to intimate
visits with a concubine the article also
asserts that during his imprisonment El
Chapo has read two books the Spanish
novel el final del Ave Phoenix by Marta
kwarrel and john green's highschool love
story Paper Towns now first off I don't
view the Paper Towns isn't so much a
love story as a learning that
romanticizing someone isn't the same
thing as loving them story but yeah
apparently El Chapo has read one of my
books which you know is a little weird I
mean I guess Paper Towns is about a
larger-than-life character who enjoys
well-plotted escapes and has a bit of an
empathy deficit so maybe he found it
relatable I have so many questions did
he like the book how was the Spanish
translation did he been and radar
did he emerge from the reading
experience imagining Santa more
complexly but the biggest question I
have is like how how did a book I wrote
eight years ago end up in a prison in
Juarez Mexico which led to an even
larger question I started wondering how
like anyone ever found my books you
might be thinking while everyone else
was reading them or whatever but in fact
that is not true while my books have
been far more widely read than I ever
could have imagined more than 97% of
Americans haven't read one so my readers
are still in a relatively small Club
Hank it's just like you know you a few
other people El Chapo in fact at this
point reading any book is almost a
countercultural activity like a recent
survey found that almost 30 percent of
American adults read no books in the
last year so nerdfighters no worries if
you haven't read one of my books but if
you have I'm wondering if you can share
with me in comments how you came to read
it alright let me get the story of any
book that found its way
you through strange and unexpected
circumstances and yes I am hoping to use
these answers for inspiration in the
coming months as I work on my new story
speaking of which I should go back to
that Hank I will see you on Friday